[Musique]
pour malakmi c'est un jour de
fête un jour
sacré elle se prépare à partir au temple
faire une offrande très
personnelle aujourd'hui je vais donner
mes cheveux à Dieu j'avais des problèmes
de santé depuis quelques semaines et
j'ai dû aller à l'hôpital ma santé s'est
vite amélioré grâce à
lui je sais que Dieu m'a toujours aidé à
surmonter les épreuves que j'ai eu dans
ma vie c'est pourquoi je veux le
remercier pour remercier les dieux elle
a chois
tiumala ce temple du sud de l'Inde dédié
à balaji un des dieux les plus puissants
de la religion
hindou il aurait le pouvoir d'exaucer
tous les
vœux chaque jour des milliers de fidèles
viennent de très loin pour célébrer ici
les grands événements la naissance d'un
enfant ou encore les
mariages en offrand au dieu des fleurs
des noix de coco mais pas se
va offrir au temp ce qu'elle a de plus
précieux sa
[Applaudissements]
chevelure nous promettons à Dieu de lui
offrir nos cheveux s'il résout nos
problèmes certains donnent toutes leur
chevelur d'autres seulement quelques
mèches en fonction de ce qu'ils ont
promis moi je préfère offrir tous mes
cheveux c'est ce que je suis venu faire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
mais ce que tous ces fidèles ignorent
c'est que derrière cet acte de dévotion
se cache un commerce très
lucratif car leurs chevelures seront
vendues aux enchères puis exporté dans
le monde entier où elles s'arrache à
prix
[Musique]
d'or
en Inde du Sud la tradition veut qu'on
donne au moins une fois dans sa vie sa
chevelure au
[Musique]
dieu je me sens vraiment heureuse et
plus
[Musique]
légère c'est la 5è fois que Malmi fait
cette offrande
surprenante
[Musique]
la première fois j'ai promis mes cheveux
à balaj car mon mari avait eu des
problèmes de santé la deuxè fois c'était
moi et les autres fois c'est parce que
mes filles avaient eu des complications
au cours de leur
grossesse pour qu'il exce nos vux il
faut bien lui donner quelque chose en
retour et pour nous les femmes les
cheveux sont
notre c'est ce qui nous r
belle on puisse lui
[Musique]
faire comme à alakmi 15000 pèlerins vont
passer ce jour-là entre les mains des
barbiers du
[Musique]
temple allez on avance on
avance allez par ici
donne-moi ton ticket il faut que tu
ailles au comptoir
41 le rasage ne dure que quelques
minutes le samedi et le dimanche je r
jusqu'à 50 têtes par
jour ça même arrivver d'en raser 200 en
une
journée
les enfants sont soumis au même
rituel ne pleur pas ça va bien se passer
je t' expliquer pourquoi on doit te
raser après tu auras des cheveux encore
plus longs et plus
beau quand les enfants atent leè année
la tradition veut que nous donnion leurs
cheveux c'est l'OF préférée de
moi aussi j'ai respecté cette tradition
quand j'étais
[Applaudissements]
petite à peine rasé les cheveux sont
ramassés et soigneusement déposé dans
ses grands bidons conservé comme un
précieux
[Musique]
trésor il paraît qu'ils font du commerce
avec ses
cheveux dit que le temple les vendait
aux enchères pour des centaines de
milliers d'euros mais je ne sais pas
exactement ce qu'ils deviennent
après des médicaments je crois mais je
ne suis pas
[Applaudissements]
sûr le temple reste discret sur le
commerce de ses offrandes il assure
seulement que la vente lui permet de
financer des œuvres
sociales mais les dons des fidèles font
surtout la fortune de dizain
d'exportateurs indiens en Inde faire du
business avec la religion ne choque
personne le marché du cheveux sélévé à
plus de 10 milliards
d'euros pour remonter cette étrange
filière il faut se rendre à une aine de
kilomètres du temple à tanouu une petite
ville de l'Andra
pradesch c'est là que les cheveux sont
expédiés dans cette usine gardée comme
une forteresse
elle a remporté les enchères organisé
chaque année par le
[Musique]
temple tu peux mettre tout ça là ça pèse
combien des montagnes de cheveux qui
vont connaître ici une impressionnante
cure de soin et de
beauté
ils vont être lavés séchés puis traités
et même
colorés viendra ensuite le brossage et
l'assemblage une longue transformation
pour un résultat stupéfiant les cheveux
d'indienne sont complètement
métamorphosé pour devenir des extensions
de toutes les couleurs et de toutes les
formes
elles finiront sur la tête d'occidental
en quête de volume et de longueur pour
leur
coiffure et voici le magicien du chev
ravidran Vanka un des plus grands
exportateurs du
pays j'ai voyagé dans le monde entier et
j'ai observé les femmes pour voir
quelles étaient leur goût et queles
étaient les modes dans chaque région du
monde à partir de là j'ai pu créer tous
ces
modèles mais ça représente beaucoup de
compét pour obtenir par
exemple ces boucles
serrées
au total plus de 50 femmes vont
travailler sur ces
mèches un travail délicat minutieux
réservé aux femmes jugé plus appliqué
que les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hommes
[Musique]
les femmes sont des déesses pour moi ce
sont elles qui offr leur cheveux au
temple ce sont elles qui les travaill
dans mon usine et ce sont ell aussi
quient mes produits dans le monde vous
le devez beaucoup oui je le dois
tout grâce aux femmes van connu une
ascension sociale
spectaculaire enfant d'une famille
modeste de tanouou aujourd'hui on se
lève sur son passage il est devenu un
des hommes d'affaires les plus respectés
de la région un compte de fé à
l'indienne qu'il expose partout dans son
bureau ça c'est le prix du meilleur
entrepreneur de l'année
2010 celui-là c'est le prix du meilleur
exportateur sur cette photo c'était le
premier ministre de
l'époque et là le président de
l'Inde j'étais tellement fier ce jour-l
oir un prix du président indien en
personne j'étais vraiment
ému son empire génère un chiffre
d'affaires de 5 million d'euros avec des
clients dans plus de 50 pays avec ses
cheveux Vanka espère conquérir le
monde dans chaque pays il y a des femmes
et les femmes ont besoin de
Chev dans chaque nation un jour vous
verrez mes produits seront vendus dans
tous les pays qu'il soit riches ou
pauvre et à terme je voudrais pouvoir
employer 10000 personnes dans ma région
c'est ça mon
but la réussite de Vanka c'est aussi une
chance pour la petite ville de
tanouou l'usine emploie 3000 femmes des
environs
des mères de famille des jeunes filles
comme
[Musique]
bagasserie après la fermeture de l'usine
elle rentre avec sa petite sœur elle
aussi ouvrière chez Vanka elles font
partie de la communauté chrétienne de
tanuku dans le religion on ne donne
jamais sa chevelure en
offrande
c'est ma
[Musique]
maison dans la famille de bagasserie
tous travaillent à l'usine de cheveux la
mère les trois sœurs et même le père
agent de
sécurité viens t'asseoir
ici ne va pas regarder la télé ouvre ton
cahier et viens
travailler
grâce à leur travail la famille a vu son
confort'amélioré
elle a pu s'offrir cette petite maison
ils en rêv tous depuis des
années ils sont où les P ver ils sont là
juste à côté de
toi
avant on vivait dans une Hut et on avait
du mal à joindre les debout mais Van
nous a aidé pour financer les études de
ma sœur pour son mariage aussi et 2 ans
plus tard quand on lui a dit que l'eau
s'infiltrait partout pendant la mousson
et qu'on était envahi par les mous il
nous a prêté de l'argent pour construire
cette nouvelle
maison pour la mer de bagasserie
l'ouverture de l'usine a été une
bénédiction elle qui a connu le travail
au champ de longues
années on a beaucoup de chance d'avoir
ce travail d'ouvrière sinon on devrait
retourner dans les
risières toute la journée il fallait
marcher dans la boue sous le soleil
alors qu'à l'usine on reste toujours à
notre poste et on travaille avec nos
mains vous savez les cheveux ça fait
travailler beaucoup de monde ici et ça
nous permet de bien gagner notre vie
[Musique]
en se développant ces 20 dernières
années le marché des cheveux a changé le
quotidien de milliers de villageois de
landandra
[Musique]
pradesch l'Inde du Sud a trouvé sa
matière première
[Musique]
inépuisable aujourd'hui les chercheurs
d'or noir viennent de très loin pour la
trouver Arthur de mange arpente le sud
de l'Inde depuis 2 ans il est un des
principaux fournisseurs français de
cheveux
d'extension parmi ses clients les plus
grands salons de beauté
parisien ici dans cette campagne reculée
il vient dénicher les plus beau
spécim mais il n'a pas toujours été
facile de se faire accepter dans un
milieu encore
confidentiel vraiment un marché très
très fermé et pour y accéder c'est vrai
qu'il faut jouer des coudes et
enfoncerfoncer des portes ce qui est
vraiment compliqué en surtout en
étranger mais une fois que vous y
arrivez c'est un monde extraordinaire
qui à découvrir
passionant un monde dans lequel le
français
détonne
bonjour comment allez-vous bienvenue
dans notre
usine Arthur fait affaire avec Vanka
depuis 2 ans au fil des mois
l'exportateur indien est devenu un de
ses principaux
fournisseurs il SP il les cheveux oui il
prépare les cheveux du
temple
d'accord SP les cheveux gris des cheveux
noirs oui on sépare les cheveux colorés
et les cheveux naturellement
gris Arthur ne s'approvisionne qu'en
pour ses
extensions le seul pays au monde où il
peut trouver la quantité mais surtout la
qualité de cheveux qu'il
recherche ce sont les cheveux du temple
après le lavage et vous voyez ils sont
très beaux très
soyeux
[Musique]
ils sont vraiment
beaux nchetons que des cheveux indiens
tout d'abord
pour le simple fait qu'on a un cheveux
qui est exactement la même morphologie
que le cheveux européen et audelà de ça
beaucoup utilisent des produits
chimiques qui déter le cheveux le monde
entier quasiment utilise ses produits
chimiques les décolorations les
colorations
scheveuxire tout ça qui abîme énormément
énormément de cheveux les indiennes sont
vraiment les seules à ne pas utiliser ce
ce genre de produit comme vous pouvez le
voir des cheveux qui viennent d'être
d'être coupés sont absolument absolument
superbes c'est les meilleurs cheveux du
monde et de loin je pense
[Musique]
sincèrement Vanka tient encore à montrer
à Arthur son produit phare le plus rare
et le plus
cher
et ça ce sont les cheveux les plus longs
qu'on est ils font 1
M30
1 très
impressionn des cheveux de cette
longueur sont rarement disponibles alors
dès qu'on en a on les garde pour
Arthur en Inde c'est vraiment dans la
culture de ne jamais se couper les
cheveux et de de les laisser pousser
tant que tant qu'on va pas auutant donc
effectivement il y a qu'ici qu'on
trouvera non seulement cette qualité de
cheveux mais en plus ce type de longueur
qui qui sont vraiment vraiment très
impressionnante et qui sont très demandé
pour les
shooting et le monde de la mode de New
York à Paris est pris à dépenser des
fortunes pour s'offrir les cheveux
indiens les prix sont toujours en
fonction de de la demande particulière
du client mais là on est sur des prix
qui peuvent aisément dépasser 2500 €
pour pour ça par
exemple mais Vanka ne fait pas que dans
le
[Musique]
luxe
le cheveux bas de gamme représente
l'essentiel de ces
ventes ce sont de petites boules de poil
plutôt repoussant à priori sans valeur
pourtant une fois travailler elles
partiront en Chine pour devenir des
perruques et même le rebut sera
curieusement utilisé on va en extraire
de la protéine qui servira notamment
dans la production de nourriture pour
bébé
[Musique]
tout est utile dans le cheveux humain
rien n gâé mais rassurez-vous le cheveux
ne va pas être utilisé tel quel il va
être décomposé et transformé en une
poudre blanche c'est un produit
pharmaceutique ces cheveux multiples
usages ne viennent pas du temple ils
sont réc un pe partout dans les Cagnes
indienes milliers d'hommes et de
femmes leur métier unique au monde
ramasseur de
[Musique]
cheveux au petit matin et ses voisines
partent faire la tournée des villages
elles vont récolter les petites touffes
rester accroché aux brosses en échange
de quelques
roupies près d'un quart des habitants de
leur village vivent comme elle de ce
travail
insolite on achète les
cheveux le travail de JY consiste à
faire du porte à
[Musique]
porte allez même si tu as pas beaucoup
de cheveux je te les prends
je te donne 25 roupill pour
ça seulement bon je n'ai pas eu beaucoup
de client depuis ce matin alors je veux
bien vous donner
30 ça fait 10 jours que je mets mes
cheveux de côté tout ce que je récupère
sur mon peigne après m'être brossé je
les range
là c'est la première fois que je fais
ça comme je voyais tout le
mondeendreux suis dit que cétait bête de
les jeter alors que moi aussi je peux me
faire un peu
d'argent au bout d'une heure de porte à
porte jy tombe sur un paquet de cheveux
plus
conséquents à vue d'œil plusieurs
centaines de
grammes cette fois la balance est
[Musique]
nécessaire mets les cheveux sur le
[Applaudissements]
plateau si les gens nous vendent au
moins 100 g on peut se faire presque 1 €
de profit même 50 g c'est bien mais si
les gens nous vendent moins de quantité
ce n'est pas très intéressant pour nous
je sais que ça va devenir des perruques
à l'étranger je suis heureuse de me dire
que mes cheveux vont
voyager un très long voyage des brosses
indiennes jusqu'aux usines chinoises
avant l'Europe et même
[Musique]
l'Amérique
malakmi elle n'a rien gagné en échange
de ses cheveux juste la fierté d'avoir
tenu sa promesse au
Dieu de retour chez elle elle découvre
son nouveau
visage regarde mamie est chauve mamie
est chauve et
oui dans sa famille personne ne s'étonne
de son
geste vous savez ce n'est pas la
première fois que ma belle-mère donne
ses cheveux à balaji on commence à être
habitué et vous ne trouvez pas qu'elle
est moins belle comme ça pas du tout on
ne pense pas comme ça quand il s'agit de
donner ses cheveux à Dieu il n'y a pas
de raison d'avoir
honte on est content qu'elle l'a fait
moi aussi je me fais pousser les cheveux
pour les offrir au
temple vous savez qu'un kil de cheveux
coûte 250 € ah bon mais vous savez on ne
pense pas au prix auquel nos cheveux
sont revendus ou au fait que des gens
vont se faire de l'argent avec
l'important c'est notre rapport à Dieu
et quoi qu'il arrive je continuerai à
donner mes cheveux jus ma
mort et ça vous fait quoi de savoir que
vos cheveux vont devenir des extensions
qui seront peut-être porté par les
grandes star du
cinéma si ça peut leur être utile tant
mieux moi je suis contente que mes
cheveux finissent sur la tête de belles
héroïnes nous après on les regardera à
la
télévision et j'aimerais même que mes
cheveux aux
États-Unis parce que les femmes sont
vraiment belles
[Musique]
là-bas une tradition
millénaire le renoncement un signe de
féminité qui permettra ailleurs à
d'autres femmes d'être à la pointe de la
mode cheveux révèle une des facettes les
plus curieuses de l'Inde ce pays très
pieux où rien ne se perd et tout peut
trouver une seconde vie de l'autre côté
de la
[Musique]
planète